>> Georgia Higley: So,
I'm Georgia Higley.
I'm head of the newspaper
section in the Serial
and Government Publications
Division.
And we're the home of the
comic book collection.
So, that's why I'm up here.
And I have the fortunate
duty to introduce Carol.
So, I want to welcome
everyone to this latest program
that we're sponsoring.
And this program is celebrating
one of our special collections,
The Comic Book Collection.
And it's really celebrating
one piece
of that collection,
the SPX Collection.
And the idea of the SPX
Collection goes back
to August, 2011.
When the Library signed an
agreement with SPX that lead
to the creation of
the collection.
As many of you already know,
SPX sponsors an annual festival
in Bethesda, Maryland.
And it gives artists, writers
and publishers of comic art
and its multitude of forms,
the opportunity to meet
and exhibit their material.
The Library aquires independent
comics and cartoon art
from publishers and creators,
appearing at the festival.
As well as through the
annual Ignatz Award winners.
And through todays talk,
we're actually recognizing
the rewards of this agreement.
Because to date, over
5,200 items have come
to the Library, through SPX.
And that has been a
wonderful boon for us.
Because, of course,
it is something
that probably we would
not have received
through our traditional means,
which is copyright deposit.
And the annual talk
that we're sponsoring,
such as this one today,
is always held the
Friday before the start
of the SPX Festival weekend.
So, today, we're very fortunate
to have a claimed cartoonist,
painter, writer, educator.
And I'm sure there are a whole
lot more occupations l could
list, Carol Tyler, as
this year's speaker.
She will be discussing her
creative life in "Comics To a T,
The Triumphs and Troubles
of Telling the Tyler Story."
She's a pioneer of the
autobiographical comic genre.
And she uses her own experience
to kind of tackle issues
of human experience, with
grace, humor and style.
Tyler's works are too
many to mention here.
But they've appeared
in Women's Comics,
where her first works
were published.
Twisted Sisters,
Weirdo, LA Weekly,
among many other publications.
She has received
numerous awards.
Notably named on the list
of the top 100 cartoonist
of the century.
Tyler's 2015 book, "A
Soldiers Heart, the Campaign
to Understand My WW Two Veteran
Father," about her dad's trauma
from World War Two and
its impact on her family.
Exemplifies the autographical
comic genre
that she has really
made her own.
It received a host of
awards and nominations.
Eleven Eisner awards,
two Ignatz nominations.
And was twice a finalist
for the LA Times Book Prize.
Alex Dubin, [assumed spelling]
of the Los Angeles Times
Book Review, considered it,
"Not just Tyler's
masterpiece, but arguably one
of the 21st centuries
best comics."
Others have compared
it favorably
to Art Spiegelman's "Maus."
Her latest book, "Fab4
Mania," I love that name.
Details her personal
obsession with the Beatles.
And her concert going
experience,
as told from her 13-year-old
self's point of view.
As she once described
it, "It's me reconnecting
with the person I was,
before life came along."
So, before I turn the
podium over the Carol,
I just want to point out
that we've got a display
of Carol's works.
Including both "Soldiers Heart"
and "Fab4 Mania," on the tables
on the far side of the room.
So, after the formal programs
over, please go take a look.
And I want to put a
plug in for an exhibit
over in the Jefferson building
that also has Carol's work
in it, "Drawn to Purpose."
It's worth crossing the street
to take a look at that exhibit.
So, please welcome Carol Tyler.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Carol Tyler: Thank you.
Hello, everybody.
And thanks for making
the trip out here
to the Madison Building today.
It's nice to see everyone.
This is such a beautiful
building.
And I love libraries.
I love the idea of being
at the Library of Congress.
I want to thank you so much
for inviting me to
be a part of this.
It's terrific.
So, yeah, we'll do
this PowerPoint now.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, I've -- I'm going to try
to be relaxed, as
much as possible.
I'm a little bit nervous.
This is a biggy.
The Library of Congress,
people have said whoo,
because it is a deal.
Anyway, "Comics to a T."
So, as you heard
in the intro, yes,
I am an autobiographical
cartoonist.
And I've been doing this for
what, 40 something years, maybe.
I don't know, sort of.
I guess. I work with
my family members.
This is my daughter,
up there on the left.
You see her a lot in "Late
Bloomer," as a little tot.
This is my husband Justin Green,
the author of "Binky Brown."
Miserable, over a cup
of coffee and life.
And that's my core
family you see there.
My original family.
That would be my brother,
sister, my other little brother.
Me, I'm in the middle.
And my mom and dad.
And I've spent most of my career
telling stories about this crew.
One of the first stories
about the family was --
in fact, one of the
first stories I ever did,
was this one called
"Uncovered Property."
And it features, mom, dad,
Jenna, Joe, Jimmy and dog,
like I showed in
the picture before.
Thank you for pointing this out.
This story I did, "The
Hannah Story," which was
about my sisters'
accidental death in 1947.
I did this in 1993.
I think it was published in '94.
And it was named as being
on the top 100 cartoonists
of the 20th century.
I was very honored about that.
It's not here in
your collection.
You got to get a copy
of "The Job Thing."
It's everybody's favorite.
This is where I have a
little problem though.
Because I put the word
shitty on the cover.
Stories about shitty jobs.
Because at the time, I kept
saying, the jobs are shitty.
What other word could
there possibly be?
But as I've kind of matured
and gone through life,
it's kind of difficult
to say, oh, no,
I'm a distinguished cartoonist.
And here's my book about
shitty jobs [brief laughter].
Just the wrong word.
But I don't know how
else to describe it.
But even in "The Job
Thing," which was
about these terrible jobs
I've had, that we've all had.
The image you see, the cartoon
you see, is about my in-laws,
at the time or they
weren't in-laws at the time,
they were my first
set of in-laws.
There's been many
[brief laughter].
Okay, this is -- I was in this
group called "Twisted Sisters,"
which was Aline and Diane
and there's Phoebe
Gloeckner in the middle.
Aline Crumb, Diane Noomin.
And that's me in the vest.
I was wearing a vest because
until maybe the, maybe the turn
of the nine -- 20,
2,000, I never wore a bra.
And so, I wanted to kind
of cover up a little bit.
So, that's me in the vest with
a glass of wine, going oh,
boy, I hope I'm covered.
And that's that man cover.
"Late Bloomer."
I wanted to do a collection
-- this was in like, 2005.
I wanted to put together all
the stories that I had done
when I was -- "Late
Bloomer," is a collection
about all the stories I did
while I was raising Julia.
And felt like it was coming
late because it was in the --
I was in my late
forties, early fifties.
And this was Kim Thompson's
idea, at Fantagraphics.
Let's call it "Late Bloomer."
So, that became the title.
It's a collection of things like
"Anatomy of a New Mom," which is
on display over there.
A page from "Migrant
Mother," where my kid is
out of control at an airport.
And I had a bad infection
and oh.
But one of the things I did here
is, I was really proud to try
to work panels in such a
way that it moved the eye
in a unique way,
around the page.
We always read from upper
left to lower right.
And I wanted to do this kind
of flow technique
with moving the eye.
The same way that she was
running around the airport.
Yeah, that's our family.
That's me and Justin
and our kid, Julia.
And this is in a story
called "The Outrage."
And I have me, as
a horrible entity.
And he's an old armadillo.
And our little kid is
going, ooh, stop it!
You know, kids try
to get in the middle.
But I use animal personification
a lot in "Soldiers Heart."
Yeah, this is -- I'm not afraid
to say anything in comics.
I never have been.
And this is a panel
from "The Outrage."
Where I get -- I had this child
and I felt like she was just --
I hate to say it, but she was
just like, on me on the time.
And I came to a point --
now they call it
postpartum psychosis.
But at the time, nobody
was talking about this.
So, I did.
And I wrote it in this.
I wrote about how I saw
these knives on the table.
I got freaked out and threw
them out and threw them
out the window, really.
And tried to collect myself.
So, this was very common.
Many women have thanked me for
bringing this to the attention.
This was before what's
her name did.
I did this in print.
Here's my new book "Fab4 Mania."
Whoo! So, much fun!
Oh, gosh, we'll talk
about that later.
But first, I do want to talk
about "Soldier's Heart."
Because it is the book that took
most of my cartooning career.
And it took me ten
years to do this book.
It began as three
separate books.
A lot of people think that
"Soldier's Heart," down here,
which is "You'll Never
Know," book three,
is the "Soldier's Heart" here.
But it's not -- this was Gary
Groth trying to make sure
that the title of the book had
the right -- for new audience.
So, "You'll Never Know."
The title comes from my parent's
sweetheart song, when they meet.
And there's also
other references
to not knowing what the heck
was going on with my dad
and my parents in their lives.
And as children, we
always look to our parents.
And they're so big and awesome.
And I always had questions about
what was going on with them.
The first book had a wood cover.
Because I really wanted to focus
on my dad's building trades
and his workshop stuff.
The second one is more
about the collateral damage
or the difficulty it took on my
mom and the rest of the family.
That's why it has the
least kind of background.
And then granite, because there
was so much of book three,
where we come to D.C.
And there's so much
about the story that's
written in stone.
So, it started like this, where
one day I picked up the phone
and all I heard was
"rivers of blood!"
I was, like, Dad, what?
Huh, what?
Because at that time, my dad
never really communicated well.
In fact, my whole life,
he just wasn't much
of a -- we weren't close.
He was there.
He did his job.
He was a great.
"Give me a kiss, yeah, give me
a kiss right here, yeah, okay."
But he was not a smooth dude.
He'd never say, "Come here
and tell me about your day"
or anything like that.
And my mom had a stroke and
he had nobody to talk to.
So, he called me
up and said this.
So, I right away grabbed a
notebook and started writing
down everything he said.
"Citations, North Africa,"
and all this kind of stuff.
I didn't know what this meant.
Because my knowledge about --
I knew he was in World War Two.
I knew about the medals
or that there was some --
I didn't know any of that
stuff that you see there.
Patches, I didn't know
what any of that meant.
Now I know, of course,
because I researched.
And he had a photograph album.
And all the pictures in there
were pretty much fun, funny.
I've had a lot of
people tell me that.
That they get the funny,
fun stories from their dads
or grandfathers, about the war.
When in truth, he was
pretty raging angry.
And most of the time,
especially when he got older.
And the older he got and the --
especially towards the end of
his life, he got more and more
into these fits of rage.
That in this panel,
the panel before this,
my mother is terrified.
Because he's tearing
the house apart.
And she calls me up
and says, "Oh, come --
come over, he's going
crazy, he's going mad."
And he gave me the book --
I had asked him if I
could please borrow
that booklet of photographs.
And he forgot he
gave them to me.
And he thought I stole them.
So, he was tearing the house
apart looking for them.
And I knew I couldn't
tell a story about dad,
without telling a
story about mom.
Julia, our child, Justin and I's
child, there's Justin and dad.
And if you -- and me.
If you look at the
photograph here,
look at the look on his face.
Because I had just
given him the "365 Days
of World War Two" book.
And he -- that photograph
says it all.
This was the hardest thing
for him to have to deal with.
It was going to take
a lot of driving,
along with note collecting
and phone calls.
That was my little
driving companion, Baby.
And they lived on the
other side of Indiana.
And I show their house,
like you see there.
I lived, at that time,
in Oakley in Cincinnati.
And I show the building
like this.
And this is kind of a map
of the state of Indiana.
Cincinnati is right
close to the state line.
And they lived on the other
state line, towards Illinois.
And so, I-74 and
I-70, were my buddies.
And I just drove up
and down that road.
It was a four-hour
drive back and forth.
And often had to go, at
various times, without notice.
But I usually went every
ten days, two weeks,
maybe about twice a month, to
see them, for about ten years.
And trying to get
this stuff together.
There's my house, where I ended
up moving to in Cincinnati.
And there's a drawing of
my neighborhood, my street.
There's always football
playing going on.
I ripped out my lawn
because I didn't want to mow
and planted all that
[brief laughter].
Oh, that's my studio up there.
You see where the
American flag is.
And there's -- it's
a two family.
And I did the whole book
up just by those windows.
So, let's get started.
Writing comes first.
When you do a big
story of any kind,
of course, you get your idea.
And some of them come in
the middle of the night.
And some of them you map out
in -- and I use anything.
Yellow pages, backs
of envelopes,
anything I could find.
I did a lot of research.
I had to read books.
And learned to read
these World War Two maps.
I learned all this
information about what --
these campaigns and generals
and official duty
booklets and everything.
Oh, gosh, this is just
the tip of the iceberg.
I have at least ten stacks
of just the note taking.
Just papers that
overwhelm the box.
And that's just the notes.
And then there's little
artifacts like that sheet music
that has the music to my parents
love song, "You'll Never Know."
There was so many layout
challenges to this book.
Because I am a person that can't
-- I have -- I'd be a good DJ.
I don't like repeating,
formats, songs, anything.
So, I had to change it up.
I feel like I have to
change it up all the time.
And at one point I had it
out on adding machine tape.
I thought, well, I'll try it.
I wrote on the wall.
I don't have any pictures
of the wall because its
since been painted over.
But I would write on the
wall, some of these things.
And then I got into having
these big sheets of paper.
And I'd list everything out.
And then I'd go in
with a red pen and pick
out the things I
thought were important.
And then I connected
pages together.
This isn't trying
to figure out --
because I knew some
of the story.
I knew the outcome.
I knew where I wanted --
sorry, where I wanted
to go with this story.
And I knew a lot of stuff.
It was organizing and getting
all the ducks in a row.
Post-it-Notes.
Sometimes they're helpful.
Yeah, I used those.
I did anything I could, to
try and pull this together.
This is a big giant
sheet of some kind
of -- it's about this big.
And I just drew the double
spread of all the pages.
And that mark through,
it means accomplished.
And in this one, you'll see,
like, orange Post-it-Notes
and yellow Post-it-Notes.
It was something like,
maybe orange meant --
you know how in the book I
have just the military part.
I talk about just his story.
Him telling me, "And
then we went up over here
and I got a casa in Italy."
So, whenever it's just him
telling a military story,
that was orange.
And then I think the pink down
here might have been kid crisis.
And then I had -- because
you have to understand,
I was telling mom and dad's
story from World War Two.
I was telling dad's
I was telling my parents
story now, as elderly people.
I was also talking about how
that folded into my life now.
So, I had my kid now.
At the time, she was 12, 13.
My older parents now.
But then me as a kid,
my parents as a kid.
So, we're talking about
really looking back
at all of these decades.
Trying to juggle that
and seamlessly pull it
through because of the
story that I wanted to tell.
Eventually, yeah,
great, I got this table
and just gridded it off.
And put it all -- I
think this is book two.
I don't know why there's
an adding machine there
because [brief laughter]
I don't know.
But on the wall in the
background, is the configuration
of why a dog wags their
tail, the way it does.
The other day I was
looking at that.
It's, like, what is that?
Oh, yeah, this means, I'm
really happy or something.
The book took over my life.
It took over my house.
Kim Thompson, insisted
that we work with some sort
of clarity, you need to know.
Because the whole
book, I would do it.
I would scan it.
And would send it through the
mail or I mean, through the --
some kind of server thing,
to -- over the internet.
So, I never -- in the old
days, you would do artwork,
like some of the early
work you see over there.
I would do artwork and
then you'd box it up,
tape it up, take it to FedEx.
Ship it and then
they'd receive it.
So, I never once walked
into Fantagraphics
graphics department.
It was all done by spreadsheet.
And file names and file numbers.
And I forgot to put
numbers in those three,
"You'll Never Know," books.
But I did put numbers in
"The Soldier's Heart."
But this is all a
configuration of that.
All right.
You start drawing with a pencil.
I got one in my hair
right here today.
I use a yellow number
one, Ticonderoga.
And a good old pencil sharpener.
I work on Strathmore,
500 series plate paper.
The draw -- the work
starts like that.
And ends up looking like that.
Let's have an ink party!
Whoo! Because I mixed, custom
mixed, the colors I would need.
You see magic 50 is, blood.
I think there's tank, underline
color, my mom's hair, redhead.
You know, different -- any
color I needed, I custom mixed.
In fact, I had 53 colors
that I worked with.
And made a chart.
So, like, oh, I need, mom's
hair, okay, that's going
to be -- and I'd
look at the chart.
And I'd know which one of those
little containers would have the
color I was looking for.
Kind of bonkers.
And I drew everything
with these two vehicles,
the pen and this brush.
The brush made the whole
-- made the distance.
The whole book, I did
with the one brush.
It's a Windsor Newton
series seven-one.
And the pen points
are 788 Esterbrook.
I was so terrified -- oh,
all those pens you see
over there, ignore them.
Some of them have application,
but mostly I did those.
But I was so terrified I was
going to run out of pen points,
that I cornered the market on
eBay of 788's [brief laughter].
So, I own them all.
If you have them, they're mine.
I bought boxes and boxes of
them because I was so afraid.
This is one of the
first drawings I did.
And I was so nervous about how
it was going to look, you know,
how I was going to do this.
And I thought, well, what you do
when you do any kind of story,
is you start with what you know.
And you start with
what you want to do.
And I really liked
drawing objects and stuff.
So, this was my dad's
collection of toxic materials.
That in the book, I talk
about he's having --
he's getting chemo.
And I tell the lady,
you should of just,
you know, this is Mr. Toxic.
And I tell this story
about how he had all
of these horrible,
horrible things.
And I -- they were
going to be moving.
And I said, "Dad, you can't take
this stuff to the new place.
Come on, this is stupid.
You're not going to
be taking benzene
and lead and all this stuff."
"Oh, it's my stuff!
Keep your hands the
hell away from it!"
And I said, "No, you're not
-- I'm not going to allow it.
You're not taking it."
So, I put it all in the
back of his Cadillac
that he started with
a screwdriver.
And ran it to the toxic place.
And they were like, "Oh, yeah,
lady, just put it over there."
Okay. So, then I went
home, it's in the book.
I ran back and was like,
oh, wait, I forgot,
there's a couple -- there's
one more with something
that was oozing out
on the sides.
You know, eating
through the canister.
So, I thought, I'll
just run this back
to the toxic place and the dump.
I go back there and
they went, "Oh, yeah,
you need to go down here.
And then when you get way
to the back of the yard,
you take a left and
there's three buildings.
It's the last final building
and it's back in the corner."
And I went, oh, okay.
So, there's -- these
buildings are empty, right?
And this is at some
of kind of dump.
And I drive all the way back.
And I go all the way back there.
And there, in this huge
big warehouse building,
in the corner, is this
little pile of stuff
with caution tape all around it.
Like, stay back,
don't come near it.
It was like, it made
me sadder then anything
to see it that way.
The other challenge was, how
am I going to draw these people
that I know what they look like.
But I also have an image
of them in my minds eye.
So, I had to tell
everybody to get over it.
These may not -- people may
not look like you exactly.
Don't hold me to
account on that.
It was so complicated, I
had to make custom furniture
to accommodate the
pages and steps
that I'd have to
take in between.
It looks like a wreck
because it is.
But I made tilt up tables.
I made, you know, a
saw, I got those skills.
Just plywood, trying to
think of what I needed.
Build shelves for things
like fake army men
and stuff like that.
So, I also want to --
this is funny on the wall.
At the time, I thought, I
need some guiding principles.
So, my mom, with her stroke,
was able to bang out, "Carol,
you'll ever know that
I love you, mom."
Because she knew the book was
called "You'll Never Know."
But see how it always
kind of stuck to the right
because of her stroke.
And my theory was, oh, you know,
I need family support,
plant-based diet.
Exercise and all this
stuff, good sleep.
My dad's theories are smoke,
drink, do everything wrong.
Hope you're forgiven.
Forget about it.
[ Laughter ]
So, here's some of the
layout configurations.
To tell dad's -- dad and mom's
story, I went to this kind
of office supply
look from the 40s.
I noticed that all the
paper had this kind
of double black and
red line thing.
And I got some stamps
to do the numbers.
And then I would do four across.
And this is the fourplex.
And since it's "Kid Crisis,"
the -- it's in black and white.
And everything is
outlined in red.
Six packs, I made a lot of books
that has a lot of six packs.
It's not just random
crazy stuff.
I got an order here.
A six pack means there
are six panels on a page.
And if I'm looking back, I
often did the wavy line, like,
from the old photograph
technique.
Or sometimes I would put a
strip between the panels.
Or sometimes I would actually
put the quarter inch gutter
between the panels,
margins, sorry.
This is a variation on a 12.
So, one and two are together.
This is about a trip to the
archives in Saint Louis.
And they wouldn't let my dad in.
They wouldn't let my mom
in, to see his own records.
I had to go through
Freedom of Information Act.
It was crazy.
You can read about
it in the book.
But this is 12th.
This is a variation on the
four, where what I wanted
to do was show me
talking to them.
And I put them in color and I'm
over here in black and white.
Because I had just come
out of a kid crisis thing.
And down the middle
is the destination.
I was asking dad to
come to the memorial.
And he's like, "What?
I don't want to go there."
And I said, "Yes, you do.
Come on, I got a personal
invitation here from Tom Hanks."
He said, "Who's Tom Hanks?"
And my mom is, with her
stroke, she's thinking,
"Hanks, a star, let me think.
Private. Private something."
I'm like, "Oh, no, he's
that silver screen dude."
Okay, here's Hanks.
"Please join me in
honoring the achievements
of our greatest generation,
which includes you, Charlie."
My moms thinking, "Ryan?"
"Form letter."
"Okay, form letter or
not, we're going dad."
"Connotation and archivist."
And like that marine said,
"It will take us a while,
but we're doing this.
Are you in?"
"Yes," he said, "I guess so."
And so, you see the memorial,
the stars, Tom Hanks and part
of the memorial features there.
And then my mom,
it comes to her.
"Saving Ryan Seacrest."
[ Laughter ]
I always have surprises for
you readers, in all of my work.
You just have to
read it closely.
Sometimes I would
do full page panels.
For some reason, there's
something missing.
But had the pencil
drawing behind it.
God, I hope this
is not a problem.
But here we are at
the National Archives
out in College Park,
doing some research.
Came up bust.
And this is the drawing
about how it goes from pencil
to ink, from the left side.
Pencil to ink on the right side.
And then the double
spread of both of them.
And what I wanted to show
here was the feeling you get
when you walk into the
World War Two Memorial.
You get this -- you kind
of walk down in there.
But then you get this uplifting,
especially when you walk
into the two sides,
Atlantic, Pacific.
And I wanted to pull those
beautiful elements that are
up in the building structure.
I wanted to pull them
up into the space.
So -- and that's how -- I
was just like, oh, my God.
It just so moving.
And for dad, too.
I took a lot of pictures, when
we were here and used them.
And you can see his
hat there, him looking.
That's all I had.
But I had to construct
the drawing, you know,
kind of in a different way,
using a photographic reference.
I also knew in the back
of the book I wanted
to have a lady swinging a kid.
So, I random found a lady
and asked her permission
and used that for that.
This was a made up -- you
know, when you're in Indiana
and it's bleak and
it's Christmas time,
there's nothing on the roads.
But these -- I call
them "Prairie pop ups,
that anchor freeway offramps,
like rivets on dungarees."
And then it was funny because
I went to Kroger, not too long
after and it was like, oh, I
drew that out of my imagination.
Sometimes I just make shit up.
Sorry for the cussing.
But I was trying to
convey that everybody
that I was highlighting
in the book,
the five of us all had
issues going on in the mind.
I wanted to talk about that.
And this is a page where before
texting or whatever that is,
talking, bloop, bloop.
I was trying to show --
I drew this before then.
I was trying to show a
conversation that my mom
and my sister and I were
having about the time
that dad's Cadillac caught on
fire on the way back from chemo.
And so, I have anything
that she says,
with her green headband,
in green.
My mom's is in red.
And mine's in blue.
And we're trying to weave
together the details
of what happened and who was
where and what was going on.
And this is another example
of trying to keep everybody --
keep the action flowing.
You go from left to
right, in the first.
And then it goes down and you go
across back the page
backwards the other way.
And then it comes back through
and you go through here.
Because I wanted
to show the action
of driving across the country.
Or driving across
the state of Indiana.
Now this one is very
interesting.
Because there's a panel that
starts here and, of course,
it ends at the bottom right.
But what I wanted
to do, was to spell
out the thesis of the book.
This was the infamous page five.
I was laying out the
book, I was like,
I don't know what I'm
going to do with page five.
I had something that
lead up to it.
And everything else behind it.
And page five just stuck,
stuck, stuck, stuck.
One morning I woke up and I
went, I got it, page five.
Start at the bottom.
Dad gets the plywood and
he puts it in the truck.
And then he's going to drive
up through the landscape.
You see? He drives past
a sign that says, "not."
It's up there, Arby's
sign, "not."
And then there's a tire
store that says "all."
And you see "scars,"
the cars have letters
on the top of them, "scars."
"Not all scars."
The cow says, "are" urgh.
And then in the sky it
spells out "visible."
"Not all scars are visible."
Which was the post-traumatic
stress disorder.
Otherwise known as shell shock,
for World War Two Veterans.
And some pages, I just
had to build impact.
This is the most stunning
statistic I came across.
Was that if you take the
60 million people that died
in World War Two and
you break that down,
that's 25,462 people a day.
Now, can you imagine the
24-hour news cycle dealing
with that today?
Every day for six years.
Trouble. And I'm going
to apologize in advance
because this part makes me cry.
But I will go on.
So, my companion, throughout
the whole book, Baby.
One day, she was like this.
And I realized that I
had to put her down.
And this was at the same time
that it turned out that mom,
at 93, was diagnosed
with lung cancer.
A good long life, but
still mom, you know.
So, now, it changed that -- I
didn't have the book done yet.
So, it changed that
I would be caregiving
at a four-hour distance.
Along with teaching.
Along with trying to
get the book done.
Mom had a contribution
in the book.
I made her, because she's
the original art person.
I mean, gosh, where do
you get things from?
She -- I made her sit down
and gave her some color.
And she -- and I said, "You
got to draw this page, mom.
It's got to be in the book."
She's like, "No.
Why do you have to reveal so
much about our personal lives?
It's nobody's business."
It's, like, kind of too late
for that, is what I told her.
So, she made this drawing,
"Out of War Came My Children."
And she drew this.
And you can see it goes off to
the right because of her stroke.
But the four -- her four living
children are on the right side.
And then the one who passed
away, Hannah, that I told you
about from "The Hannah Story."
She's on the left
with tears coming out.
She said, "They're not flowers,
they're stars in bloom."
See, they were married in 1943.
And then she has that -- she
says, "That's the fog of war,"
that splotch below the flowers.
Flowers, I mean stars.
The trouble with doing family
stories, is they die on you.
And you have to come back to
the studio and finish the job.
So, this particular panel,
that's in "Soldier's Heart,"
I wrote a date underneath it.
Because she passed
away on 2-4-2012.
And I depicted here
as a manatee.
My sister, who was
my stalwart helper
and fun friend my whole
life, who did all my editing.
Always calling me
out for bullshit.
Although, she was a former nun.
She never used that word.
She thought I cussed too much.
I had to -- I got this call,
come here, something's wrong.
So, I went over there and they
put her in the operating room.
They found stage
four ovarian cancer.
This is before my
mom passed away.
But my sister was also
caregiving her daughter
with autism and her
husband with Alzheimer's.
And there's Justin there.
We would -- I had
lots of flowers.
Like I said, I ripped out my
lawn and grew roses and stuff.
And I was taking flowers
everywhere I went.
Now, it started to be
I'd take my art pages
and I'd take these flowers
to scenes like you see here.
And everywhere I
went, people were laid
out in recliners, sick.
And I'd have to run these pages
back and forth from my house.
I did these pages for
"Soldier's Heart,"
in lobbies, waiting rooms.
There's elevators.
I got -- I finally figured out
what the elevator buttons mean,
as I rode them so much.
Every -- anywhere, hospital
-- doctors offices, anyplace.
I was just dragging
my pages along.
Those little tray
table things on --
by the table, are
really good for drawing.
I just come in, hey,
mom, how you doing.
And just clear it
off and set the pages
out and just draw away.
And then I got this
e-mail from Kim Thompson.
He's my editor and
publisher of these books.
So, it's like, oh, gosh.
In the meanwhile, at home,
my daughter had some sort
of goofy -- oh, it was horrible.
Had to have surgery
on her sinuses
and her -- everything was bad.
Her boyfriend was
a heroin addict.
He was sweet, though.
I mean, we liked him.
He was living with us.
But I'd come home and the
house would look like this.
So, I'd be caregiving over here,
running up and down the freeway.
I'd come home and
there would be --
look at the mayonnaise
splotch on the table.
Just everything was
always chaotic, gross.
Look, I'd have to
-- I'd have to board
up the windows in the basement.
Because guys that
he owed money to,
were trying to break
in all the time.
Or he'd pawn my stuff.
So, I was taking
pictures of everything,
before I'd go anywhere.
This is just the
nonsense that was going
on in the neighborhood.
There'd be all this noise and
turmoil and crap going on.
I'd see needles everywhere.
But my life was, either
school, at home trying
to clean up that mess.
Or get on the freeway,
take my pages.
I'd go take care of the people,
in conditions like this, often.
Or how about coming to school,
starting another semester
and they said, oh, we don't
have a classroom for you.
How am I supposed to teach?
Well, okay, I'll go down
and I got the janitor
to help me find some tables.
I had a pop-up classroom
in the hallway.
I had to teach in the hallway.
And hide the stuff every
time and drag it back out.
This is me.
I broke out in this
virus, all over my body.
I couldn't move.
I was in bed.
I couldn't lift up
my feet, nothing.
Some kind of strange thing.
Thirty days of fever.
I had a fever every single day.
And all through this, I'm
writing this book about my dad.
And he turned.
In my -- in his mind,
I was the enemy.
He accused me of
stealing his money
and all this kind of stuff.
I'd come in the house,
"What do you want now?"
I mean, he was terrible.
But I stayed the
course with Chuck.
I just kind of put
up my Spartan shield.
And while I'd be making soup
and serving it to somebody else.
I was pretty much a wreck.
My sister thought
I looked good here.
I said, I don't feel good.
But I wasn't going to
say anything to her.
I could absolutely relate to
this guy [brief laughter].
But sometimes I'd come home
and there's be a deer
in my living room.
That's the heroin
addict, God bless him.
He was really cute.
We really liked him.
And then a cute new dog
showed up on the porch.
It was, like, hey, yeah.
And I was able to get my
mom and my sister together.
To do this -- to get to this
moment, you have no idea.
It involved me driving,
fending off my dad.
Getting a truck.
Getting mom out of her
nursing home, into this car
and taking her to the hospital.
Ugh. My sister, bless her heart,
such an education stalwart.
She had a PHD, despite
all of her troubles.
And here was the day when,
just before she passed away,
they gave her an
Emeritus Status.
And here -- and I'm
trying to give her my hair.
I used it in an art show.
I cut my hair off in solidarity.
So, yeah, she was on her death
bed and I had a deadline.
Because I was doing work
for Cincinnati Magazine.
And so, this is a story about
-- she used to love to swim.
And she was a teacher.
So, this is about me
teaching a kid to swim.
And then when she passed away,
of course, I had a deadline.
And before I went to the
funeral, I had to talk about --
I had to come up with
this month's installment.
So, this is about Rosemary
Clooney, at a park singing
"I'll Be Loving You, Always."
And dad, we knew he
was going to get going.
And I knew that "Soldier's
Heart,"
that big fat book
was coming out.
So, I had him do
signature cards.
And by the way, Georgia,
I have a signature
card for the library.
Dad's last Christmas.
He didn't realize it
was his last Christmas.
I knew that.
So, kind of lonely.
Everybody was gone.
So, I said, "Hey, why don't
we write down all the people
from moms, that you
can remember,
from moms address book,
your Christmas card
list, on these papers."
And so, we made this chain.
And so, he was writing
down everybody's name,
that he could remember.
And then I went to the funeral
on Tuesday, his funeral.
And I got back, I think it
was Tuesday or Wednesday.
I got an e-mail from
Fantagraphics, "Oh,
we need the artwork
drawing for your dads --
for the cover, by Friday.
So, after all of this, okay,
I had to sit down and knock
out a portrait of dad.
I had just put him
in the ground.
It really does take a toll,
doing this kind of work.
It's really hard.
This is the hardest
to talk about.
Because when I did
this, this is from
"The Hannah Story,"
I told you about.
It got to me that my sister had
this terrible burn accident.
And so, I was leaning
over the drawing, crying.
And the drops were falling.
I wanted to use red
ink, you know,
to show the lines,
I made these lines.
But it was -- I was
dropping tears on the page.
So, I took a tissue
and I was dabbing it.
And it made that smear
technique that you see there.
It's from me crying.
No wonder I did the
Beatles book.
Oh, it was time, it was time.
My new book is about
mourning, though.
It's about all this stuff
I've been telling you about.
Losing everybody, living
with a heroin addict.
Everything that entails,
the impact it had
on my life it's called
the "Ephemerata."
And I began, right after mom
died, with kind of for me,
traditional page
art, making grids.
And this is -- I've got a
bunch of these little booklets
that I get at thrift
stores and stuff.
Nonsense books.
You probably have one in
your Library of Congress.
"Hex Signs and Barn
Decorations."
But I'm asking probing
questions about death.
And I call it a "Book Report."
But I've also been gravitating
towards just art with words
on it, trying to free myself.
You have to understand,
ten years of making --
using 53 colors, is
very limiting and tough.
And so, this when my
sister was just at the end.
It says, "These are the
only thoughts I have."
And I have the grim
reaper carrying her off.
But still, I'm wondering
down here,
if this is a legitimate drawing,
is it legitimate
for me to do this?
Maybe I should make
a table or something.
Something more purposeful,
make furniture.
I'm very hard on myself.
And I also tell my
students, and this is true.
When you can't do anything else
in your life, do
a self-portrait.
At least your pencil's working.
And you know that what's going
on with that head of yours.
So, I started doing --
exploring this new thing.
Like, all these objects
and mourning and deaths.
This is my great
grandmothers mourning bonnet.
She tended to both Union
and Confederate soldiers,
during the Civil War.
She was -- they called
her the "doctor."
That's -- I have
her mourning bonnet.
And in this sequence, it comes
on me and knocks me down.
So much that I have to process.
I almost can't function.
There's days where I just can't.
Because I've got
mom and dad's stuff.
I got my sisters stuff.
I got my own stuff.
My best friend down the
street, Rose, she passed away.
I got a bunch of her stuff.
My brother-in-law.
Sometimes I just sit there.
Hey, there's dad's army uniform.
There's Jimmy's bike, when
he was seven years old.
And this has become
kind of an expression
of how I feel right now.
I'm holding the impossible
Trident.
And there's pain.
I'm kind of focused on that,
but yet, I'm lost in it,
in this weird landscape.
And this -- you know,
that Grant Wood painting,
"Woman with Plants."
And she's holding plants.
There's nothing coming
out of that flower pot.
I've been making
sculptures out of thorns
because I have thorn
trees on my property.
And doing stories on saw blades.
Using some of dad's old
saw blades tell us --
and then this is
from this exhibit.
I'm going to show you and
we're going to watch it.
I'm going to show you
a link in a minute.
But these stumps represent
all the people I lost
in a three-year period.
These were close to me.
So, finally I got mom settled.
She wanted to be
near a young tree.
And that's my sister,
in the basket.
I was able to help her
with her final wishes.
Which was to be -- she was
in the convent years ago.
She died -- she went back
to the convent at the end
of her life, as an associate.
And so, I -- my brothers
and I, distributed her ashes
at the sister's cemetery.
I got my dad buried.
And in the coffin with him,
are some tools, a pipe.
And that chain of
all his friends.
I put that in there at the end.
This past June, I went
back to visit his grave.
And make sure they had
the Veteran, his stone.
And there it was.
And as I was walking
up, I thought, oh, no,
I have nothing to give.
I have nothing to bring.
You know, whether it be a shot
of whiskey or some flowers.
But I realized I
had a pencil, right?
So, I wrote on the
stone, I wrote --
I did some of the
drawings from the book.
And made a little
American flag for him.
And I love you.
Miss you, dad.
And that's his flag flying.
I was able to get a
house in Kentucky,
a farm with money he got from
being a disabled Veteran.
Because the Cincinnati
Zoo is buying my house,
so I have to move.
And so, I had to get this
other place to get started on.
So, I got this farm house.
And there's his flag.
And my little companion, Tue.
I call her Tue, T-u-e.
We're having -- she's
wearing a fascinator.
And we're having tea
at the royal wedding.
But bless her heart,
she had just gotten hit
by a car a week before.
And as she was laying in
the street, when I saw her,
I thought, oh, God, she's gone.
I went up to her
and I said, "Tue."
And she raised her head up and
said, "If you can just get me
to an emergency vet, I promise
I will stay the course with you.
Because you've lost
too many people."
And then there's farmer Jones
Justin there, with the truck
that we did all the
driving with.
And Saint Francis in the
garden, from my parents.
And they've always
had that yellow thing
that flops around in the wind.
And the farmhouse, which
I actually had visions of,
during my period of mourning.
I imagined a space where I could
do this work the "Ephemerata."
And this is the room that
I'll be doing this in.
I've already started.
So, now, I want to
show this video.
This is my art show that I had
with all the pages of the book.
[ Music ]
>> I feel this is one
of the best exhibits
that the Meyer Gallery
has really had.
And I've come here for years.
[ Music ]
It's creative, it's innovative.
It uses the space well.
You want to stay and
you want to read.
[ Music ]
>> Well, I think it's
wonderful in a variety of ways.
But mainly because, you
know, I'm a book person.
So, it's really unusual
to see an entire book
laid out like this.
[ Music ]
>> What I think about
this show is so beautiful,
is that Carol actually shows
every single page of the book
that she drew by hand
very meticulously.
[ Music ]
>> I think the other thing
I really like about this,
is that the other,
the second room,
I love the way she's done the --
she's opened her
head to the world.
Which is cleverly done
here with the doorway.
[ Music ]
>> It does kind of feel like
you're sort of coming into sort
of like a mind field with her,
with what she's doing here.
[ Music ]
>> The interior acts
as her studio.
And it also acts as
her fathers' workshop.
But kind of beyond that,
it really acts as her mind.
And the things that
are in her mind
and preoccupy her
mind and her thoughts.
And the things that
she's thinking about,
when she's generating her work.
[ Music ]
>> It's so amazing, reading the
story and sort of the pathos
that she's been through.
I mean, the books
kind of show that.
But seeing it here with all
the 3D, you know, objects
and found things, really
kind of packs a punch.
You know, I mean, kind of really
feel the grief and you know,
what she's been through.
And what her families
been through.
You know, especially,
particularly the handwritten
stuff on the walls here,
it's just, you know,
heartbreaking.
[ Music ]
>> Another thing that I
admire, is that Carol worked
out her personal
experience with her family
and her father's history.
By going through all of her
life's experiences with him.
And documenting that.
And working it through in
her own way, telling a story
about her dad and her
experience with her dad.
Painting it all, drawing it
all and reporting it all.
And working it through.
So, to me, this is
like a poetry.
It is literature.
It is psychology.
It is art.
It is drawing.
And for students, this
is wonderful to see,
that an artist can have such
a breadth of information.
That with her own talent
of being able to write
and being able to
draw, work that out.
And I feel like that joy
that she had doing this book,
is expressed in this exhibit.
[ Music ]
>> Carol Tyler: Okay.
[ Applause ]
There you go.
That's all [brief laughter].
Good bye.
[ Applause ]